Let's go to our next caller from the four
for three area code.
Who's calling today from four, four, three.
Hey, David, this is Jack.
Hey Jack, can you hear him?
Yes.
Again,
I was just wondering if you've ever heard,
are you shifting gears, um, you know who are
familiar with Ari Shapiro?
No, I'm not.
Okay.
Yeah.
You've been on the Joe Rogan show before,
right?
Yes.
Correct.
So Rogan's friend.
Yeah, he, he, I'm wondering if you've ever
heard his argument on abortion before?
Well, I might've heard the argument without
knowing he was making it.
What's, what's his argument?
Yeah.
That it is murder, but that it's murder for
convenience in that and like, it's okay.
Basically.
How do you feel about that?
I'd have to hear how he defends it.
I mean, listen, I think, I don't know how
you say that abortion is murder in the abstract
sense.
You know, a lot of times the debate becomes,
is abortion destroying life and then you'll
sometimes hear people get into these semantic
back and forths about, well it's, it's the
potential for life versus his actual, it's
actual life.
I think the more relevant question is not,
is it life?
Because so many things on this planet are
forms of life in some way.
Under the broadest definition.
The question is, are we talking about a person
when we're talking about an abortion early
on in the pregnancy?
And I've seen no solid scientific argument
that that is a person.
Um, and so that's more my guiding principle.
I guess I'd have to hear this guys a our argument,
but to really understand it.
Oh, I, I agree with you, but I just think
it's interesting the point of like, I think
what he's trying to get at is that it is a
life he's trying to, like there is the middle
ground that I do think that conservatives
don't see like, oh, it is a woman's body.
Like you like
[inaudible] what do you mean by that?
They don't, they don't believe that it's a
woman's body.
What does that mean?
No, they don't believe that it's a woman's
right to like they believe it's women moments
body, but they don't believe that it's a woman's
right to like choose whether or not that life
exists or not.
In other words, then one other, someone they
want someone other than the woman who is carrying
the potential for life to make a decision
about what the woman can do.
Correct.
Yeah, I'm against that.
Well, yeah, I am too.
And sometimes they'll like liberals don't
want to see like, oh well at, at a certain
point if you continue to let the light form
exist, it would become a guy named Steve on
the street like that.
That would happen.
Well, they use that to, their advantage is
there is a middle ground there is.
That's exactly right.
Right.
And so I think the, the, I know people, some
people hate it when I make this analogy, but
a lot of times this is the problem with simply
coming up with a set of principles and then
believing that the hard work is the principles
rather than their application.
When the application is really where most
of the thinking has to take place, and I know
people don't like this analogy, but it's like
with a speed limit.
When we say that the speed limit on a road
is 35 that doesn't mean 40 might not be safe.
When it's nice out, that doesn't mean that
you don't have to slow down to 25 when it's
icy out.
You at some point have to figure out, okay,
here is our principle for how we set speed
limits and we're gonna pick a number.
And I know it's a crude analogy to abortion,
but at a certain point, the fact that you
can't say with 100% consensus, this is the
day at which it is now a person doesn't mean
the solution is abortion is illegal.
That makes perfect sense and I agree with
you completely.
All Right, Jack, thank you for the call.
Appreciate it.
Great to hear from you.